After Warner Bros. unleashed two and a half
minutes of glorious Joker footage in early
April 2019, fans picked apart each scene,
analyzed every frame, and watched the whole
thing — multiple times and in slow-motion
— in efforts to catch every subtle reference
to pop culture and to Batman comics past.
People picked up on the wink at The King of
Comedy with Robert De Niro's casting as a
talk show host, the parallel to a classic
Joker costume in the teaser's final shots,
and the allusion to another famous pale-faced
icon, Charlie Chaplin, with the banners hanging
outside Wayne Hall.
What most may not have noticed the first,
second, or tenth time around is that the Joker
teaser also includes what could be an Easter
egg for the Riddler, a longtime foe of Batman.
At the 57-second mark of the footage, during
the scene in which Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur
Fleck is standing in an elevator at Arkham
State Hospital, viewers can spot green-ink
graffiti on the wall behind him.
Though the tag doesn't appear to hold any
deeper meaning, that punctuation mark is intriguing,
as it's the insignia of Edward Nygma, better
known as the Riddler.
Fans are beginning to think that this could
mean the Riddler is hiding in the shadows
of director Todd Phillips' version of Gotham
City.
One of the famous baddies in the Dark Knight's
rogues gallery, the Riddler has spent a ton
of time locked up in Arkham Asylum — seemingly
reimagined for Joker as Arkham State Hospital,
which apparently counts Arthur Fleck as a
regular visitor.
That this sneaky green question mark appears
not just anywhere but on an elevator in Gotham's
home for the criminally insane adds some credence
to the idea that the graffiti could be a legitimate
Riddler Easter egg, and could portend an appearance
by Nygma himself.
That would, unquestionably, be an awesome
surprise …
“Was that over the top?
I can never tell."
It wouldn't be the only clever nod to Batman
comics featured in the new Joker footage — or
the only one included in connection with Arkham
State Hospital.
Just after the camera sweeps across Gotham
City in the first few seconds, the teaser
shows Phoenix's Arthur sitting opposite a
social worker, played by Sharon Washington.
Her name tag reveals that her name is Debra
Kane.
If that surname sounds familiar, it's because
it's the same one as Batman co-creator Bob
Kane and as Batman's cousin Kate Kane, otherwise
known as Batwoman.
There are a few other names revealed in the
trailer that could be meaningful — or not.
For example, there's street sign that reads
"Jerome Avenue."
The DC television series Gotham features a
character named Jerome Valeska, who is a precursor
to the Joker, much like Arthur Fleck is the
man who eventually becomes the clownish criminal
in the upcoming Joker movie.
Then there's the existence of Holmes Pharmacy,
which appears 10 seconds into the teaser,
when Arthur is walking down the street.
Batman is known as the world's greatest detective
— and so is Sherlock Holmes.
With a little mental gymnastics, one could
deduce that Joker including a pharmacy seemingly
named for the other best fictional crime-solver
on the planet might tease how Arthur's life
connects with Bruce Wayne's.
Or maybe the production designer just liked
the look of the name "Holmes" on the sign!
Taking all this into account, it's clear how
easy it is to make something out of what very
well could be nothing.
The green question mark inked on the Arkham
State Hospital elevator is certainly interesting,
but whether it's actually a Riddler Easter
egg is anyone's guess.
Could it be?
Sure!
Might it just be Todd Phillips wanting to
tip his hat to the comics while keeping Joker
its own outside-of-the-DCEU thing?
Absolutely!
The beauty of this uncertainty is that fans
now have yet another reason to look forward
to Joker — beyond what looks to be a bang-up
performance by Phoenix.
When the film opens in theaters on October
4th, all questions shall be answered and all
potential Easter eggs will, hopefully, be
followed up on.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.